Starting with the newest edition--one of the
newest editions,  Yusuf Gatewood
The newest regent of New Orleans, Danielle Campbell
As Davina
The unofficial Mikaelson brother; Charles Michael Davis
I actually allotted extra time for screaming, so actually just go for it
Creator and executive producer, Julie Plec
The man who will break your heart, rip it out and probably eat it; Joseph Morgan
The brother with a suit for every occasion, Daniel Gillies as Elijah
Nice jacket.
Yeah give it up for that jacket!
Out of a suit and into a smokin' hot jacket!
Yeah, the one time he's not wearing a suit.
The she-wolf who is currently more wolf than she, Phoebe Tonkin
Executive producer, Michael Narducci
And everybody's favourite token human, Leah Pipes
Now I do have a lot of questions about the past season that we all enjoyed
But I think I need to address something that we just saw in that video which was new I believe
Julie, Michael who the hell were those two people and how can we make them dead?
They actually you know, it was a scene that we shot for the season finale
Uh, at the end of last year, we wanted to kind of have a little tag at the end that said,
"Oh there's danger coming in a new form"
And then we we saw the episode we preferred the ending of Klaus's emotional moment
Sort of stewing up that there were new enemies to come , and then we hadn't started shooting this year yet
Uh, you love to come to comic con and show off new footage but we didn't have any
And we thought, hmm how can we show the audience like what is in the works?
And we thought, "Oh! There's that scene!"
And it's just a hint of--Narducci it's just a hint of uh what's to come in terms of the new villians maybe.
Well yeah, we've talked a lot about how the Mikaelsons have been around for 1000 years and
somewhere along the way they probably turned a bunch of people into vampires